hello and welcome to this video playing
unit somebody on on do I have sound I
need to recheck this once in a while I
don't want to have this pin situation
again where I lost like 30 videos why
would you go to see phone okay Bishop
looks really odd on b6 I mean how are
you ever going to develop c8 and the
situation mmm like b6 Bishop e7 is a way
to prepare development of that piece but
that's not going to happen now okay his
goal is obviously to play every move
instantly and then be terrible my move
20 we know that M oh no he wants to go E
5 but that's not happening
now there's new e5 and there's also no
c5 I mean C 5 C 5 might be it's not
going to loose immediately but it's
really not great okay this is a really
nice piece
hooray got 37 so is he going to play C 5
it's not really really helping much
but yeah I still I still liked him push
this back pin he might have a 5 I don't
know
yeah it's actually if you have such an
overwhelming position a you have to make
sure that you're not thinking about it
too long because you know okay
everything looks good and then you kind
of sitting like hmm what am I actually
playing and all of a sudden you are in
charm trouble so here how to do that iam
Etsy 5s is also just just a good news I
mean yeah I guess
not sure if that was best though I mean
he has to take on e5 and then go Knight
d5 maybe cannot go back it would be
really weird
yeah I mean it's not super obvious how
I'm continuing this like I don't have a
quick I don't have a quick c6 here in
this pollution yeah maybe that wasn't
all that great to play e5 so quickly
I am the OMC father I mean
it's still quite certain I'm okay but
okay doesn't cut it really from what we
started with so yeah Quincy for angling
for c6
the immediate c6 is also interesting but
team
did a handy fire
maybe
huh maybe a blondie five at fossil 13 in
just Quincy six the rook has no square
hmm I'm said they didn't play that well
I mean move 15 or so white is just like
strategically completely winning and
somehow he still yeah it still continued
this game
yeah like him there shouldn't be
anything like yeah I don't know just too
good yet so it should not happen that I
have to really think hard later
so quince is 795 I mean why is that so
good the problem is he's got absolutely
no space
yeah it's confined to to three ranks and
this is all not working well together
either the ship is not in a good
position decision obviously bad yeah put
it on 37
yeah and TM you have such a wide variety
of choices what the engine is pointing
out is actually something that I've
thought about g4f form play on the Kings
side because well he's got if you just
took it the same you have got many more
pieces on the Kings side and f/4g 45
comes really quickly if this is
completely offside I've thought about it
but I didn't really feel like advancing
all my pawns there especially it looks
like you can do this as well and to some
extent this is probably true but yeah
starting from starting from here I don't
know a for a 5v5 I mean this is also
quite overwhelming but probably c5 is
not correct yeah the issue is this is
just a couple of things I can try to get
a past C pawn which is what happened in
the game and then won the game at the
end but I'm giving up a couple of things
as well I'm giving up d5 no this is for
stick sticks here yep theoretically
speaking I could win a pawn but this is
not a pawn you want to take I mean maybe
there's even a tactical problem but it
just doesn't make any sense to take that
yes here the light squares are weaker
and I'm not giving up my be sure
for that night yeah and I have to also
watch our this is attack now which was
not the case with the pawn on c4 so that
was probably a rushed decision yeah Luke
c1 the engine doesn't like at all it
seems you know a form a fourth kind of
logical an idea that I didn't see it all
was Luke a5 what he played later that
was an interesting move
Jack win ce7 is not great sinem a little
bit surprised that there shouldn't be at
least somewhat better ok 0.5 is not not
not 0 but the problem is is that he
cannot stop a3 right like here he has
Luke a5 and then yeah this is what I
said yeah this is Wickham cannot cover
it
Luke Luke here appears runs into Knight
c3 Jim yeah after this I'm probably ok
again but you have blundered e5 I just
planted anyone move something normal
rooks c2 ascoobis good yeah yeah but he
didn't take it and now after c6 I think
it's it's basically gone
26 is an enormous threat cannot really
stop it with anything good I'm winning
winning everything computer shows made
in 12 floors funny yeah I was just like
I'm winning this and it didn't really
play this all too well after having this
this great position out of the opening
ok guys thanks for watching